vítej zpět u série Porozumění kvantové informaci a výpočtům, jmenuji se John Watus a jsem technickým ředitelem pro vzdělávání v IBM
Quantum. Toto je 14. lekce série a druhá lekce čtvrté jednotky, která pojednává o kvantové korekci chyb.
V předchozí lekci jsme se poprvé podívali na kvantovou korekci chyb, včetně devítiqubitového Shorova kódu, který dokazuje, že
kvantová korekce chyb je v teorii možná. Také jsme probírali diskretizaci chyb, která nám umožňuje
opravovat libovolné kvantové chyby na qubitech tím, že je efektivně promítáme na bitové překlopy a fázové
překlopy. V této lekci probereme stabilizátorový formalismus, což je matematický nástroj, pomocí kterého můžeme
specifikovat a analyzovat širokou třídu kvantových kódů pro opravu chyb, známých jako stabilizátorové kódy. To zahrnuje devítiqubitový Shorův
kód spolu s mnoha dalšími příklady, včetně kódů, které jsou pravděpodobně mnohem vhodnější pro reálné kvantové
výpočetní zařízení než Shorův kód. Ne každý kvantový kód pro opravu chyb je stabilizátorový kód, ale mnoho jich je,
včetně každého příkladu, který v této sérii uvidíme. Existují zajisté zajímavé a potenciálně užitečné kvantové kódy pro opravu chyb,
které stabilizátorovými kódy nejsou, ale bývají poněkud složitější a v každém případě není
pochyb, že stabilizátorový formalismus je základním kamenem v základech kvantové korekce chyb a budeme se
na něj po zbytek jednotky hojně spoléhat. Zde je stručný přehled lekce: začneme krátkou diskusí
o Pauliho maticích a tenzorových součinech Pauliho matic, které mohou reprezentovat jak operace na qubitech, tak
měření qubitů, jak vysvětlím, a v tomto kontextu je často nazýváme pozorovatelné. Poté se vrátíme a podíváme se
znovu na repetitivní kód a uvidíme, jak ho popsat pomocí Pauliho operací a pozorovatelných, což nás informuje
a povede do obecné diskuse o stabilizátorových kódech, včetně několika příkladů, základních vlastností stabilizátorových
kódů a toho, jak provádět základní úkoly kódování, detekce chyb a jejich opravy.
Lekci začneme krátkou diskusí o Pauliho operacích, hlavně abychom připravili půdu pro
stabilizátorový formalismus, ale také abychom pozorovali několik klíčových faktů a zavedli základní terminologii. Nejprve zde jsou Pauliho
matice, včetně identity 2x2 a tří ne-identitních Pauliho matic, které budeme označovat
velkým X, Y a Z po zbytek série. Všechny čtyři tyto matice jsou unitární i hermitovské a můžeme je
ztotožnit s operacemi na qubitu, včetně operací, které bychom mohli chtít provést, i chybami, jak jsme
diskutovali v předchozí lekci. Ne-identitní Pauliho matice X, Y a Z antikomutují s navzájem,
což znamená, že XY se rovná -1 krát YX, XZ se rovná minus ZX a YZ se rovná
minus ZY, a tyto vztahy snadno ověříš vynásobením. Tyto antikomutační
vztahy jsou velmi jednoduché, ale ve stabilizátorovém formalismu a jinde jsou zcela zásadní, a konkrétně
jak uvidíme, tato znaménka mínus, která se objevují při prohazování pořadí dvou různých ne-identitních Pauliho matic v součinu, přesně odpovídají
detekci chyb ve stabilizátorovém formalismu. Máme také pravidla násobení uvedená zde: každá
Pauliho matice je svým vlastním inverzem, což je v souladu s tím, že jsou unitární i hermitovské, a pokud vynásobíš libovolné dvě různé ne-identitní
Pauliho matice, vždy dostaneš plus nebo mínus I krát zbývající ne-identitní
Pauliho matici. Zejména až na globální fázi je Y ekvivalentní X krát Z, což vysvětluje naše zaměření na chyby X a Z v
kvantové korekci chyb. X reprezentuje bitový překlop, Z reprezentuje fázový překlop, a tak až na globální fázi Y reprezentuje
oba tyto typy chyb na stejném qubitu. Tyto čtyři matice všechny reprezentují
operace nebo chyby nebo nepřítomnost chyby na jediném qubitu, ale je často pohodlné je tenzorovat dohromady
k provádění operací nebo chyb na více qubitech. Z hlediska terminologie, kdykoli mluvíme o N-qubitové Pauliho
operaci, myslíme tím tenzorový součin libovolných N Pauliho matic, jako jsou příklady zobrazené
zde. Je také běžné používat termín Pauliho operace, když je přítomna globální fáze, ale abychom věci co nejvíce zjednodušili,
budu termín Pauliho operace používat pro označení prostě tenzorového součinu Pauliho matic. Váha N-qubitové Pauliho
operace je prostě počet ne-identitních Pauliho matic v tenzorovém součinu. Například N-násobný tenzorový
součin identity 2x2 se sebou samou je Pauliho operace váhy nula. Tenzorový součin dvou Pauliho X
matic a spousty identit má váhu dvě, a tak dále. Intuitivně, váha N-qubitové
Pauliho operace je počet qubitů, na které působí netriviálně, a kvantové kódy pro opravu chyb jsou typicky
navrženy tak, aby dokázaly detekovat a opravovat chyby reprezentované Pauliho operacemi až do určité váhy. Můžeme
uvažovat o Pauliho operacích různými způsoby, včetně jako operací záměrně prováděných kvantovými gates, ale
také jako chyb, a brzy uvidíme, že Pauliho operace mohou popisovat měření. Někdy je také užitečné
uvažovat o Pauliho operacích jako o generátorech určitých množin v algebraickém smyslu, který možná poznáš,
pokud se vyznáš v teorii grup. Pokud se v teorii grup nevyznáš, to je v pořádku, pro
tuto lekci to opravdu není nezbytné, ale pokud máš zájem studovat kvantovou korekci chyb do větší hloubky, možná zjistíš, že
základní teorie grup je k tomu velmi nápomocná. Každopádně, předpokládejme, že P1 až PR jsou N-qubitové Pauliho operace,
takže P1 je N-qubitová Pauliho operace, P2 je N-qubitová Pauliho operace a tak dále. Když mluvíme o množině generované
P1 až PR, myslíme tím množinu všech matic, které lze získat vynásobením těchto matic dohromady
v libovolné kombinaci a v libovolném pořadí, přičemž každou z nich bereme tolikrát, kolikrát chceme. Za chvíli uvidíme několik příkladů,
ale nejprve zmíním notaci, kterou používáme pro označení této množiny: množina generovaná P1 až PR je
P1 až PR oddělené čárkami uvnitř úhlových závorek. Trochu to vypadá, jako bychom to mohli snadno splést
s indexovou notací, ale k tomu obecně nedochází, a toto je tradiční notace v teorii
grup. Zde je příklad množiny generované X, Y a Z. N je tedy v tomto příkladu rovno jedné, protože neexistují
žádné tenzorové součiny a bereme všechny tři ne-identitní Pauliho matice jako generátory. Ukáže se, že existuje
16 matic, které lze vygenerovat tvorbou součinů zahrnujících tyto tři matice, a to lze odvodit
pomocí pravidel násobení, která jsme viděli dříve. Konkrétně můžeme samozřejmě dostat X, Y a Z, stejně jako identitu,
a vlastně také kteroukoli z těchto čtyř matic krát I, 1 nebo mínus I, a to je vše.
WEBVTT
Tato množina je obecně známá jako Pauliho grupa. Mohli bychom také uvažovat o množině
generované pouze X a Z a v tomto případě dostaneme polovinu Pauliho grupy.
A jeden poslední příklad, alespoň prozatím: můžeme uvažovat o množině generované X tenzor X a Z tenzor Z, takže N je rovno
dvěma a tentokrát dostaneme pouze čtyři prvky, a to díky tomu, že X tenzor X a Z tenzor Z
spolu komutují. Pauliho matice a N-qubitové Pauliho operace obecněji popisují
unitární operace, ať už jde o chyby nebo záměrné operace, ale také popisují
měření. Přesněji řečeno, začínaje třemi ne-identitními Pauliho maticemi, můžeme každou z těchto
matic spojit s projektivním měřením definovaným pomocí jejich vlastních hodnot a vlastních vektorů, a zde na obrazovce máme
spektrální rozklady těchto matic, které to pomáhají objasnit. V podstatě, když mluvíme o měření X,
měření Y nebo měření Z, myslíme tím projektivní měření definované projekcemi
na vlastní prostory těchto matic, a běžně uvažujeme o vlastních hodnotách jako o odpovídajících
výsledcích měření. Například měření X je měření vzhledem k bazi plus
mínus qubitu, nebo alternativně ho můžeme popsat množinou obsahující projekce ket plus bra plus a ket
mínus bra mínus. Měření Z na druhé straně není nic jiného než měření ve standardní bázi,
přestože, jak jsem řekl, někdy ztotožňujeme vlastní hodnoty s výsledky měření, a pokud to uděláme,
pak jsou výsledky plus a minus jedna místo 0 a 1. Vlastně lze udělat něco podobného
pro libovolné hermitovské matice a termín pozorovatelná se v této situaci běžně používá. Pro Pauliho
matice a N-qubitové Pauliho operace obecněji můžeme taková měření provádět nedestruktivně pomocí
fázové estimace, a jen abychom se ujistili, že je tento diagram jasný: zde měření provádíme nedestruktivně na
horním qubitu, zatímco dolní qubit je vždy inicializován do stavu plus, jinými slovy Hadamard aplikovaný na
stav nula, protože tak funguje fázová estimace. Všimni si, že protože vlastní hodnoty
jsou v tomto případě pouze plus jedna a mínus jedna, potřebujeme pouze jeden řídicí qubit, což je dolní qubit v tomto
diagramu. Více by bylo zbytečné, protože je tu jen jeden bit přesnosti k řešení: vlastní hodnota
je buď plus jedna nebo mínus jedna, a měření je již takto dokonalé. Výsledek tohoto měření,
tedy měření ve standardní bázi v circuit, bude nula pro výsledek vlastní hodnoty plus jedna
odpovídající stavu plus v případě pozorovatelné X, a výsledek je jedna pro vlastní hodnotu mínus jedna
nebo stav mínus v tomto případě. Vše, co jsem právě řekl, se přirozeně rozšiřuje na N-qubitové Pauliho operace,
pokud mějme na paměti, že když uvažujeme o pozorovatelné, mluvíme o měření vlastních hodnot,
nikoli o měření vzhledem k bázi vlastních vektorů. Uvažujme například dvou-
qubitovou Pauliho operaci Z tenzor Z: opět jsou dvě vlastní hodnoty, plus jedna a mínus jedna, takže
měření je popsáno dvěma projekcemi. Zejména si všimni, že měření spojené s
touto pozorovatelnou není totéž jako měření obou qubitů pomocí Z měření čili měření ve standardní bázi, ale spíše je to dvou-
výsledkové projektivní měření, kde projekce jsou na prostory rozpjaté všemi vlastními vektory odpovídajícími
každé ze dvou vlastních hodnot plus jedna a mínus jedna. Jiný způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet, je, že vlastní hodnoty tenzorového
součinu jsou součiny vlastních hodnot jednotlivých matic, jejichž tenzorový součin bereme, a
protože záporná 1 krát záporná 1 je stejné jako kladná 1 krát kladná 1, toto měření
nerozlišuje mezi 00 a 11. Takže kdybychom měřili například stav fi plus Bellův stavem popsaným touto pozorovatelnou,
byli bychom si jisti, že dostaneme výsledek odpovídající vlastní hodnotě plus jedna,
a stav by zůstal nezměněn, místo aby kolaboval na 00 nebo 11, což by se stalo, kdybychom
provedli měření ve standardní bázi na obou qubitech. Takže měření Z tenzor Z není
totéž jako provádění dvou Z měření nezávisle, ale taková měření skutečně lze provádět pomocí fázové
estimace přesně stejným způsobem jako dříve, s použitím jediného řídicího qubitu, jak je znázorněno v diagramu circuit, který
se zobecňuje na libovolnou N-qubitovou Pauliho operaci místo Z tenzor Z. Když máme pouze Z Pauliho matice,
mimochodem, můžeme circuit takto zjednodušit, a to odhaluje – což je také zřejmé z projekcí definujících
měření – že provádění měření Z tenzor Z na dvou qubitech je ekvivalentní měření jejich parity
v pojmech standardní báze, a to se zobecňuje na tenzorový součin libovolného počtu Pauliho Z
matic. Dále se podíváme podruhé na tříbitový repetitivní kód, tentokrát ho formulujeme pomocí Pauliho
operací. Toto bude náš první poměrně jednoduchý příklad stabilizátorového kódu a probereme, jak tuto
myšlenku zobecnit, ale je nápomocné nejprve vidět, jak to funguje v tomto jednoduchém případě. Nejprve si vzpomeňme, že když aplikujeme
tříbitový repetitivní kód na qubity, zakódujeme daný qubitový stav alfa 0 plus beta 1 jako alfa 000 plus beta 111
a tomuto trojqubitovému kódování pro pohodlí dáme název psi. Takže psi je z definice platné trojqubitové
kódování qubitového stavu, ale pokud to chceme ověřit, stačí zkontrolovat, že následující dvě rovnice jsou pravdivé. První
rovnice říká, že aplikování Z operací na dvě levé qubity psi s ním nic nedělá, jinými slovy, že
psi je vlastní vektor Z tenzor Z tenzor identity (nebo zkráceně ZZ identita) s vlastní hodnotou jedna, a druhá
rovnice je podobná, s tím rozdílem, že Z operace jsou aplikovány na dvě pravé qubity. Myšlenka je taková, že pokud uvažujeme psi
jako lineární kombinaci stavů standardní báze, pak první rovnice implikuje, že můžeme mít nenulové koeficienty pouze pro stavy standardní báze,
kde mají dvě levé bity sudou paritu (nebo ekvivalentně jsou si rovny), a druhá rovnice implikuje, že můžeme mít nenulové
koeficienty pouze pro stavy standardní báze, pro které mají dvě pravé bity sudou paritu. Jiný způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet,
je pohlížet na tyto dvě Pauliho operace jako na pozorovatelné, a pokud bychom je měřili pomocí
zjednodušeného circuit, o němž jsem se zmínil před chvílí, pak bychom určitě dostali výsledek měření odpovídající vlastní hodnotě plus jedna,
protože psi je vlastní vektor obou pozorovatelných s vlastní hodnotou jedna. Ale tato zjednodušená verze kombinovaného
circuit pro nezávislé měření observovatelných veličin není nic jiného než náš circuit pro kontrolu parity pro 3-bitový
opakovací kód, a tak vidíme, že naše dvě rovnice dohromady jsou ekvivalentní tomu, že circuit pro kontrolu parity dává výstup 0 0,
což je syndrom, který signalizuje, že nebyly detekovány žádné chyby. Tři qubitové Pauliho operace
ZZ identita a identita ZZ se nazývají generátory stabilizátoru pro tento kód a stabilizátor kódu je množina
generovaná generátory stabilizátoru. Tato množina – stabilizátor – je zásadní matematický
objekt spojený s tímto kódem a budeme dále rozebírat roli, kterou hraje, jak lekce pokračuje. Prozatím
jen upozorním, že jsme mohli zvolit jiné generátory – například bychom mohli vybrat Z identita Z místo jednoho
z generátorů, které jsme vybrali, a kód i stabilizátor by byly úplně stejné. Dále se budeme zabývat detekcí bitových překlopení
pro tříbitový opakovací kód se zaměřením na interakce a vztahy mezi Pauliho
operacemi, které jsou zapojeny – konkrétně generátory stabilizátoru a samotnými chybami. Předpokládejme, že jsme zakódovali
qubit pomocí tříbitového opakovacího kódu a na nejlevějším qubitu dojde k chybě bitového překlopení. To způsobí, že se náš stav transformuje
podle působení operace X nebo chyby X na nejlevějším qubitu. Jak už víme, tuto chybu můžeme detekovat
provedením kontrol parity pro tříbitový opakovací kód, nebo ekvivalentně můžeme měřit
kódování nedestruktivně a zacházet s generátory stabilizátoru jako s observovatelbnými veličinami. Začněme prvním
generátorem stabilizátoru a podívejme se, co se stane. Náš stav byl ovlivněn chybou X a my chceme pochopit,
jak je měření generátoru stabilizátoru jako observovatelné veličiny touto chybou ovlivněno. X a Z antikomutují, zatímco
vše komutuje s maticí identity. Z toho plyne, že ZZ identita antikomutuje s X identita
identita – dostaneme tedy znaménko mínus, když změníme pořadí. Také víme, že ZZ identita se stavu S nijak nedotkne,
protože S je platné kódování qubitu a platná kódování jsou vždy vlastní vektory s vlastní hodnotou plus jedna obou generátorů stabilizátoru.
To nás nechá s minus X identita identita aplikovanou na S, a tedy X identita identita aplikovaná na
S je vlastním vektorem ZZ identity s vlastní hodnotou minus jedna. Podobnou úvahu můžeme provést
i pro druhý generátor stabilizátoru, ale tentokrát chyba komutuje s generátorem stabilizátoru, takže náš
poškozený stav je opět vlastním vektorem generátoru stabilizátoru, ale tentokrát je vlastní hodnota kladná.
Náš poškozený stav je tedy vlastním vektorem obou generátorů stabilizátoru a to, zda je vlastní hodnota plus jedna nebo
minus jedna, závisí na tom, zda chyba komutuje nebo antikomutuje s každým generátorem stabilizátoru. Pro první
z nich chyba a generátor stabilizátoru antikomutují, pro druhý komutují, a vždy to bude jedno nebo druhé, protože jakékoli dvě
Pauliho operace buď komutují, nebo antikomutují. Přitom samotný stav S nehraje moc důležitou
roli – stačí, že generátory stabilizátoru působí na tento stav triviálně. Takže když přemýšlíme o
detekci chyb, nemusíme se zabývat konkrétním zakódovaným stavem – záleží jen na tom, zda chyba komutuje nebo antikomutuje
s každým generátorem stabilizátoru. Sestavme tedy tabulku s jedním řádkem pro každý generátor stabilizátoru
a jedním sloupcem pro každou chybu. Zde jsem zahrnul pouze chyby odpovídající jedinému bitovému překlopení
i žádné chybě, která je znázorněna identitou třikrát tensorem se sebou samou. Mohli bychom přidat další sloupce pro jiné chyby, pokud bychom chtěli,
ale prozatím se zaměříme jen na tyto chyby. Záznamy v tabulce jsou buď plus jedna, nebo minus jedna, podle toho,
zda chyba a generátor stabilizátoru komutují nebo antikomutují. Pro každou chybu v tabulce tedy můžeme nahlédnout
do příslušného sloupce a zjistit, jak tato chyba transformuje libovolné kódování na vlastní vektor s vlastní hodnotou plus jedna nebo minus jedna
každého generátoru stabilizátoru. Tyto sloupce přesně odpovídají syndromu, který bychom získali z
kontrol parity, jež jsou ekvivalentní nedestruktivním měřením generátorů stabilizátoru jako
observovatelných veličin. Záznamy v tabulce jsou samozřejmě plus jedna a minus jedna, nikoli nuly a jedničky,
a pokud chceš, můžeš syndromy vnímat jako odpovídající binární řetězce místo sloupců s plus jedničkami a minus jedničkami. Je tu však
přímá korespondence – jen abych ještě explicitněji propojil syndromy a vlastní hodnoty
budu tyto vektory plus jedniček a minus jedniček nadále nazývat syndromy. Syndromy nám
říkají něco o tom, jaká chyba nastala, a konkrétně – víme-li, že nastala jedna z těchto čtyř možných chyb,
syndrom nám ukáže, která to byla, a my ji opravíme tím, že znovu aplikujeme danou chybu.
Dále řeknu trochu více o syndromech – konkrétně se podíváme blíže na
jejich algebraické vlastnosti. Naše kódování jsou tříqubitové stavy, tedy jednotkové vektory v
osmidimenzionálním komplexním vektorovém prostoru. Čtyři možné syndromy tento osmidimenzionální prostor
rozdělují na čtyři dvoudimenzionální podprostory – to znamená, že vektory v kterémkoli z těchto podprostorů nám vždy dají stejný
syndrom. Podrobněji: toto schéma ilustruje, jak je osmidimenzionální prostor rozdělen.
Každý generátor stabilizátoru rozdělí prostor na dva podprostory stejné dimenze – prostor vlastních vektorů s hodnotou plus jedna
a prostor vlastních vektorů s hodnotou minus jedna. Například vlastní vektory ZZ identity s hodnotou plus jedna jsou lineární kombinace
standardních bázových stavů, pro které mají dvě nejlevější bity sudou paritu, a vlastní vektory s hodnotou minus jedna jsou lineární
kombinace standardních bázových stavů, pro které mají dvě nejlevější bity lichou paritu. Situace je podobná pro
druhý generátor stabilizátoru, jen se jedná o dvě nejpravější bity místo nejlevějších. Tyto čtyři podprostory se dají snadno
popsat – právě proto, že jde o velmi jednoduchý kód. Zejména podprostor
odpovídající syndromu plus jedna +1 je prostor rozepnutý stavem |000⟩ a stavem |111⟩, což je prostor platných
kódování – tomu se říká kódový prostor. Obecně jsou tyto prostory rozepnuty standardními bázovými stavy
zobrazenými v příslušných políčcích, i když to nemusí být hned jasné. Syndromy také
rozdělují všechny tříqubitové Pauliho operace – reprezentující možné Pauliho chyby – do čtyř stejně velkých kolekcí
podle toho, jaký syndrom by daná chyba způsobila. Například každá Pauliho operace,
která komutuje s oběma generátory stabilizátoru, dá syndrom plus jedna plus jedna. Z 64 možných tříqubitových
Pauliho operací jich v této kategorii je přesně 16, včetně tří zmíněných na obrazovce – a stejně tak pro ostatní tři
syndromy. To není zřejmé, ale je to pravda. Tato základní vlastnost – že syndromy rozdělují jak stavový prostor,
v němž kódování žijí, tak všechny možné Pauliho operace v prostoru, do stejně velkých částí – je
obecně platná pro stabilizátorové kódy, které brzy přesně definujeme. I když je to spíše odbočka,
stojí za zmínku, že Pauliho operace, které komutují s oběma generátory stabilizátoru, neboli ekvivalentně
Pauliho operace, jejichž výsledkem je syndrom plus jedna +1, ale které nejsou samy o sobě proporcionální prvkům stabilizátoru, se chovají stejně jako
jednoqubitové Pauliho operace na logickém qubitu, který jsme zakódovali. Například XXX komutuje s
oběma generátory stabilizátoru, ale není proporcionální žádnému prvku stabilizátoru, a skutečně je zřejmé,
když se nad tímto kódem zamyslíš, že účinek této operace na kódování je ekvivalentní gate X na
logickém qubitu, který byl zakódován. A opět – to se zobecňuje na všechny stabilizátorové kódy. Nyní je čas definovat stabilizátorové
kódy obecně. Funguje to tak, že uděláme něco zcela analogického tomu, co jsme právě probrali pro
tříbitový opakovací kód, jen zvolíme jiné generátory stabilizátoru, které budu označovat P1
až PR. Pro účely tohoto výkladu musí být všechny tyto generátory stabilizátoru n-qubitovými Pauliho operacemi,
kde n je počet qubitů použitých pro kódování. Nemůžeme zvolit libovolnou sadu generátorů stabilizátoru –
musí splňovat několik základních podmínek. Za prvé, generátory stabilizátoru musí všechny komutovat navzájem.
V případě tříbitového opakovacího kódu jsme se tím nezabývali, ale je snadné ověřit, že ZZ identita a identita
ZZ skutečně komutují, protože Z komutuje samo se sebou a vše komutuje s
identitou. U stabilizátorových kódů se složitějšími generátory – zejména tam, kde se
v generátorech stabilizátoru vyskytují jak X, tak Z – je to důležitá podmínka, kterou je třeba
ověřit. Jeden způsob, jak pochopit potřebu této podmínky, je, že budeme zacházet s generátory stabilizátoru jako s observovatelbnými veličinami, a tím, že budeme požadovat, aby
všechny komutovaly, zajistíme, že pořadí, ve kterém tato měření provádíme,
nebude mít vliv na výsledek. Za druhé, generátory stabilizátoru musí tvořit tzv. minimální generující množinu, což znamená, že pokud bychom
odebrali jakýkoli z nich, dostali bychom menší stabilizátor. Jeden způsob, jak to matematicky vyjádřit, je ukázán zde na
obrazovce. Striktně vzato, tato podmínka není pro funkci stabilizátorového kódu zásadní
z operačního hlediska, a někdy má smysl uvažovat o neminimálních generujících množinách, jak uvidíme v příští lekci. Ale
pro účely analýzy stabilizátorových kódů a popisu jejich vlastností budeme předpokládat, že tato podmínka
je splněna. V zásadě tato podmínka zaručuje, že každá observovatelná veličina, kterou měříme k získání syndromu,
přidává informaci o možných chybách, místo aby byla redundantní a poskytovala výsledky snadno odvoditelné z jiných generátorů stabilizátoru.
A konečně musí existovat alespoň jeden nenulový vektor, který je fixován všemi
generátory stabilizátoru. To se ukáže být ekvivalentní požadavku, aby minus jednakrát identita na n qubitech
nebyla obsažena ve stabilizátoru. To není zřejmé, ale podstatné je, že je možné zvolit minimální generující
množinu n-qubitových Pauliho operací, které všechny vzájemně komutují, a přesto neexistuje žádný vektor, který by byl současně vlastním vektorem s hodnotou plus jedna
všech z nich. Tuto možnost nechceme uvažovat, protože kódy bez žádných platných kódování nejsou
zajímavé. To jsou tedy požadavky na generátory stabilizátoru pro stabilizátorový kód. Pokud máme sadu generátorů, která
tyto podmínky splňuje, máme platný stabilizátorový kód a můžeme zkoumat jeho vlastnosti. Existuje mnoho
různých stabilizátorových kódů s různými vlastnostmi, které je dělají zajímavými nebo méně zajímavými, ale všechny splňují určité základní
vlastnosti připomínající ty, které jsme již pozorovali pro tříbitový opakovací kód.
Za chvíli se podíváme na příklady, ale předtím zmíním, že kódovým prostorem stabilizátorového kódu rozumíme podprostor
n-qubitového stavového prostoru, který obsahuje každý vektor, jenž je současně vlastním vektorem s hodnotou plus jedna každého z
generátorů stabilizátoru. To je podprostor n-qubitového stavového prostoru, v němž žijí platná kódování. O tomto podprostoru toho bude
víc řečeno, jak lekce pokračuje. Nyní se podívejme na několik příkladů stabilizátorových
kódů. Zde je příklad, který jsme již probrali – obyčejný 3-bitový opakovací kód. Můžeme také vyjádřit
upravenou verzi tohoto kódu z předchozí lekce, která dokáže detekovat fázové překlopení místo bitového překlopení, jako stabilizátorový kód, jak je ukázáno
zde. Tentokrát generátory stabilizátoru měří observovatelné veličiny XX místo ZZ, takže se jedná v zásadě
o kontroly parity v bázi plus-mínus místo standardní báze. V obou případech
hned vidíme, že máme platný stabilizátorový kód, protože generátory stabilizátoru komutují, jsou to minimální
generující množiny a kódový prostor je netriviální, jak už víme. Ale je také docela zřejmé, že
nemůžeme vygenerovat minus jednu krát identita. A zde je 9-qubitový Shorův kód, který je také stabilizátorovým kódem
vyjádřeným prostřednictvím generátorů stabilizátoru. V tomto případě máme v zásadě tři kopie tříbitového
opakovacího kódu – jednu pro každý ze tří bloků tří qubitů – a také poslední dva generátory stabilizátoru, které
mají tvar připomínající circuit, který jsme viděli v předchozí lekci pro detekci fázových překlopení. Jiný způsob, jak na tyto poslední dva generátory stabilizátoru nahlížet, je, že mají přesně stejný tvar jako
u tříbitového opakovacího kódu pro fázová překlopení, jen nahrazujeme XXX za X. Důvodem je,
že XXX odpovídá operaci X na logickém qubitu zakódovaném pomocí 3-bitového opakovacího kódu.
To je ale odbočka a teď to není potřeba řešit. V případě, že to není jasné, za chvíli se podíváme na několik
dalších příkladů. Předtím však zmíním, že při popisu stabilizátorových kódů se často vynechávají symboly tensorového součinu, protože to
usnadňuje čtení. Takto vypadají tyto kódy bez symbolů tensorového součinu.
Jsou to samozřejmě tensorové součiny a ne obyčejné maticové součiny – jen vynecháváme symboly tensorového součinu, aby to bylo méně
přeplněné a vzory byly jasnější. Zde je další příklad – nazývá se
7-qubitový Steaneův kód a má docela pozoruhodné vlastnosti. Vrátíme se k němu
v průběhu zbývajících lekcí tohoto bloku, ale pro tuto chvíli můžeme jednoduše ověřit, že se jedná o platný stabilizátorový
kód. Konkrétně první tři generátory stabilizátoru zjevně komutují navzájem, protože Z komutuje samo se sebou
a identita komutuje se vším. Situace je podobná pro poslední tři, takže zbývá
zkontrolovat, zda když vezmeme jeden ze Z-generátorů stabilizátoru a jeden z X-generátorů stabilizátoru, komutují.
A je snadné projít devět možných párů a ověřit, že ve všech těchto případech vždy
dojde k tomu, že X a Z se na stejné pozici shodují sudý počet-krát, takže oba generátory komutují,
stejně jako XX a ZZ komutují. Je to minimální generující množina s netriviálním kódovým prostorem,
ale v tomto videu to nebudu dokazovat – nechám to na tobě k přemýšlení, pokud chceš. 7-qubitový Steaneův kód je podobný
9-qubitovému Shorovu kódu v tom smyslu, že kóduje jeden qubit a umožňuje opravu libovolné chyby na jednom qubitu, ale vyžaduje jen
sedm qubitů místo devíti. To ale není nejmenší počet qubitů potřebný pro kód opravující chyby, který
kóduje qubit a opravuje libovolnou chybu na jediném qubitu. Zde je stabilizátorový kód, který se
obvykle nazývá prostě 5-qubitový kód – také kóduje jeden qubit a dokáže opravit libovolnou jednoqubitovou chybu.
A pět je nejmenší počet qubitů, pro který je to možné. Zde je další příklad stabilizátorového
kódu, i když to ve skutečnosti není kód v pravém slova smyslu, protože kódový prostor je
jednorozměrný. Konkrétně kódový prostor tohoto kódu je prostor rozepnutý ebitem, neboli jinými slovy stavem phi plus –
Bellovým stavem. Takže tímto kódem nemůžeš vlastně kódovat žádné qubity, ale je to stále platný stabilizátorový kód, kde kódový
prostor je jednorozměrný. A je možné udělat něco podobného pro stav GHZ.
To jsou tedy příklady stabilizátorových kódů a v příští lekci jich uvidíme nekonečně mnoho.
Předpokládejme, že máme stabilizátorový kód. Přirozená otázka, kterou si o něm položit –
možná první, která přijde na mysl – je, kolik qubitů kóduje. Tato otázka má velmi jednoduchou
odpověď. Abychom ji vysvětlili, buďme přesní ohledně uvažovaného stabilizátorového kódu. Máme R n-qubitových
generátorů stabilizátoru P1 až PR, které splňují tři požadavky zmíněné dříve – konkrétně, že
generátory stabilizátoru všechny navzájem komutují, je to minimální generující množina (takže bychom nedostali stejný
stabilizátor, kdybychom odebrali jeden z generátorů) a v kódovém prostoru existuje alespoň jeden nenulový vektor.
Jak ukazuje věta zobrazená na obrazovce, pak musí platit, že kódový prostor stabilizátorového kódu má
dimenzi 2 na mocninu n minus r, nebo jinak řečeno, pomocí tohoto kódu můžeme kódovat n
minus r qubitů. Intuitivně: máme n qubitů v kódování a každý
generátor stabilizátoru efektivně odebere jeden qubit z hlediska toho, kolik qubitů můžeme kódovat.
Tato věta není příliš těžké dokázat a za chvíli ti ukážu důkaz. Ale nejdřív se podíváme na
několik příkladů. Začněme obyčejným 3-bitovým opakovacím kódem: máme tři qubity v kódování,
takže n je rovno třem, a jsou tu R=2 generátory stabilizátoru, takže můžeme kódovat jeden
qubit. Všimni si, že to nesouvisí s tím, jaké chyby nebo kolik chyb lze detekovat nebo
opravit – to je jiná věc. Jde jen o tvrzení ohledně dimenze kódového
prostoru. Jako další příklad vezměme 5-qubitový kód: máme pět qubitů a čtyři
generátory stabilizátoru, takže kódový prostor má opět dimenzi dva, což znamená, že tímto kódem můžeme kódovat jeden qubit.
A ještě jeden příklad: pro ebitový stabilizátorový kód máme dva qubity a dva generátory stabilizátoru, takže
kódový prostor je jednorozměrný – a jak jsem zmínil dříve, je to prostor rozepnutý stavem phi plus Bellovým stavem.
Až budeme pokračovat, uvidíme další příklady, včetně kódů, kde můžeme kódovat více než jeden qubit. Ale teď se
podívejme, jak můžeme větu dokázat. První věcí, kterou je třeba pozorovat, je, že protože generátory stabilizátoru
komutují, tvoří minimální generující množinu a protože každá Pauliho operace je svým vlastním inversem, každý
prvek stabilizátoru lze vyjádřit jednoznačným způsobem jako součin, kde každý generátor stabilizátoru
PK umocníme na AK, kde každé AK je buď 0, nebo 1, a výsledky pak vynásobíme
dohromady. Jinak řečeno: každý prvek stabilizátoru dostaneme vynásobením nějaké podmnožiny
generátorů stabilizátoru a z různých podmnožin nikdy nedostaneme stejný prvek stabilizátoru. Z toho plyne,
že jediný způsob, jak tímto způsobem vyjádřit n-qubitovou operaci identity, je, aby všechny mocniny byly
nulové. Dále definujme piK jako projekci na prostor vlastních vektorů PK s hodnotou plus jedna pro každé K od 1 do R. Existuje
jednoduchý vzorec pro tuto projekci – stačí zprůměrovat PK s identitou na n qubitech, čímž se hodnoty vlastních čísel plus jedna ponechají beze změny
a všechny hodnoty minus jedna se posunou na nulu.
Kódový prostor je definován jako množina všech vektorů, které jsou současně vlastními vektory s hodnotou plus jedna všech
generátorů stabilizátoru. Protože generátory stabilizátoru komutují, musí komutovat i projekce, z čehož plyne,
že součin těchto projekcí je také projekce – konkrétně projekce na
průnik podprostorů, na které jednotlivé projekce promítají, neboli jinými slovy projekce na
kódový prostor. Tento součin můžeme rozepsat a dostaneme průměr přes každý
prvek stabilizátoru. A konečně, protože dimenze libovolného podprostoru je rovna
stopě projekce na tento podprostor, zjistíme, že dimenze kódového prostoru je průměr stop přes prvky
stabilizátoru. Ale s výjimkou n-qubitové operace identity musí mít všechny ostatní prvky stabilizátoru
stopu rovnou nule, protože všechny tři ne-identitní Pauliho matice mají stopu nula. Stopa n-qubitové operace identity
je 2 na n, takže dostaneme, že dimenze kódového prostoru je 2 na n minus r – čímž je věta dokázána.
Dále řeknu trochu o tom, jak lze pomocí stabilizátorových kódů qubity kódovat. Ale nejdřív
potřebujeme zavést Cliffordovy operace. Cliffordovy operace jsou unitární operace na libovolném počtu
qubitů, které lze implementovat kvantovými circuits s omezenou sadou gates – konkrétně Hadamard gates, S gates
a controlled-NOT gates. Všimni si, že T gate není zahrnut, ani Toffoliho gate nebo Fredkinův
gate. A nejenže tyto gates nejsou v tomto seznamu – ve skutečnosti není možné tyto gates
implementovat pomocí těch uvedených. Takže nejsou Cliffordovými operacemi. Pauliho operace na druhou stranu
jsou Cliffordovy operace a konkrétně je lze implementovat pomocí sekvencí Hadamard a S
gates. To je jednoduchý způsob, jak definovat Cliffordovy operace, ale nevysvětluje to,
proč jsou takto definovány nebo co je na této konkrétní sbírce gates zvláštního. Zde je skutečný důvod, proč jsou Cliffordovy operace definovány
takto. Až na globální fázi jsou n-qubitové Cliffordovy operace přesně ta unitární
operace, která vždy transformují Pauliho operace na Pauliho operace konjugací. Přesněji řečeno, n-bitová
unitární operace U je Cliffordova operace až na globální fázový faktor tehdy a jen tehdy, když pro každou n-qubitovou Pauliho
operaci dá konjugace dané Pauliho operace pomocí U výsledek plus nebo minus jedna krát nějaká možná jiná n-
qubitová Pauliho operace. Snadno ověříš, že tato vlastnost platí pro Hadamard gates, S
gates a CNOT gates, takže nutně platí pro circuits sestavené z těchto gates. Co je těžší dokázat, je,
že to platí i v opačném směru – tedy že pokud nám dají konkrétní n-bitovou unitární operaci U splňující tuto
vlastnost, musí být možné ji až na globální fázi implementovat pouze pomocí Hadamard, S a CNOT
gates. Důkaz tohoto tvrzení nebudu procházet, ale je to pravda a pokud tě to zajímá, můžeš si ho vyhledat.
Cliffordovy operace nejsou univerzální pro kvantové výpočty – to znamená, že nemůžeme spouštět libovolné
kvantové výpočty pouze pomocí Hadamard, S a CNOT gates. Ve skutečnosti existuje pro danou hodnotu n pouze konečně mnoho
n-qubitových Cliffordových operací, takže je to diskrétní množina operací. Na rozdíl od
univerzální sady kvantových gates tedy nemůžeme approximovat libovolné unitární operace na libovolnou přesnost. A
ve skutečnosti provádění Cliffordových operací na standardních bázových stavech následované měřeními standardní báze neumožňuje
provádět výpočty, které jsou mimo dosah klasických algoritmů, protože výpočty tohoto tvaru lze efektivně simulovat
klasicky. Tento fakt je znám jako Gottesman-Knillův teorém a standardní důkaz tohoto teorému je v jistém smyslu
založen na stabilizátorovém formalismu. Konkrétně to funguje tak, že sledujeme, jak Cliffordovy operace transformují Pauliho
operace konjugací – což lze dělat efektivně – a z toho odvozujeme, co výpočty dělají s
qubity. Co to tedy má společného se stabilizátorovými kódy? Stabilizátorový kód nám poskytuje
kódový prostor určité dimenze a my máme volnost, jak tento prostor využít – nic nás nenutí kódovat
qubity do tohoto prostoru konkrétním způsobem. Ale vždy bude možné provést kódování pomocí Cliffordovy operace
jako enkodéru. To je pěkné, protože Cliffordovy operace jsou relativně jednoduché ve srovnání s libovolnými unitárními
operacemi. Existují způsoby, jak optimalizovat jejich implementaci – fungující podobně jako důkaz Gottesman-Knillova
teorému – a výsledkem je, že circuits pro jejich implementaci nikdy nemusí být příliš
velké. Konkrétně kódování pomocí Cliffordovy operace vždy vyžaduje o trochu méně než kvadratický počet gates –
protože to platí pro každou Cliffordovu operaci. Takže závěr je, že pro daný stabilizátorový kód je vždy
možné efektivně kódovat qubity pomocí tohoto kódu a matematické nástroje užitečné pro pochopení Cliffordových operací s tím mohou pomoci.
Například zde je enkodér pro 7-qubitový Steaneův kód – jde o Cliffordovu operaci a ukázalo se,
že tento enkodér S gates vůbec nepotřebuje. Pro obecné stabilizátorové kódy funguje detekce chyb následovně:
Jako dříve budeme předpokládat, že máme n-qubitové generátory stabilizátoru P1 až PR a označme E jako n-qubitovou Pauliho
operaci reprezentující hypotetickou chybu na kódování. Uvažujeme pouze Pauliho
operace jako chyby – mimochodem proto, že diskretizace chyb funguje stejným způsobem pro libovolné stabilizátorové kódy jako pro 9-qubitový Shorův
kód. Způsob, jakým chyby kontrolujeme, je měřit každý generátor stabilizátoru jako
observovatelnou veličinu. Existuje R generátorů stabilizátoru, takže to dává R výsledků, z nichž každý je plus jedna nebo minus jedna
(nebo binární hodnota, pokud dáváš přednost přiřazení nuly k plus jedné a jedničky k minus jedné). Těchto R výsledků
dohromady tvoří syndrom – stejně jako u tříbitového opakovacího kódu, kde R bylo rovno
dvěma. Obecně existují tři možné případy pro chybu E z hlediska její detekce a jsou následující. Za prvé,
může se stát, že E je ve stabilizátoru, což znamená, že je možné E vygenerovat z generátorů stabilizátoru, nebo
o trochu obecněji, že E je ekvivalentní prvku stabilizátoru až na globální
fázi. V tomto případě E vlastně vůbec není chybou, protože nemá žádný vliv na kódový prostor – až na to, že může
vnést globální fázi, která nemá žádný efekt. Takže o takových chybách se vůbec nemusíme starat.
Jakýkoli netriviální vliv, který by mohla mít, nastane mimo kódový prostor, takže nás to
netýká. Mnohem větší starosti působí možnost, že E není ve stabilizátoru ani s globální fází,
ale přesto komutuje s každým jednotlivým generátorem stabilizátoru. Pamatuj, že
antikomutace chyby s generátorem stabilizátoru způsobuje, že se v syndromu někde objeví minus jedna.
Ale to se v tomto případě nestane, takže jde o chybu, která skutečně mění vektory v kódovém prostoru
netriviálním způsobem. To víme proto, že jinak by byla proporcionální k prvku stabilizátoru. Ale tato chyba
kódem projde nezdetekována. Toto je tedy špatný případ – máme chybu, která potenciálně mění
kvantovou informaci, kterou jsme zakódovali, ale kód si toho nevšimne. Například u tříbitového
opakovacího kódu patří XXX do této kategorie. A poslední možností je, že E
antikomutuje alespoň s jedním generátorem stabilizátoru – to znamená, že kód tuto chybu detekuje, protože
dostaneme syndrom s alespoň jednou hodnotou minus jedna, což signalizuje, že se něco stalo, a my se musíme pokusit chybu opravit.
To jsou tedy možnosti. Z terminologického hlediska:
vzdáleností stabilizátorového kódu rozumíme minimální váhu Pauliho operace, která spadá
do druhé kategorie – tedy mění kódový prostor netriviálním způsobem, ale kód to
nedetekuje. A když říkáme, že stabilizátorový kód je [[n,m,d]] stabilizátorový kód
(s dvojitými hranatými závorkami, jak je vidět na obrazovce), znamená to, že kódování mají délku n qubitů,
kód je schopen kódovat m qubitů (takže kódový prostor má dimenzi 2 na m) a jeho vzdálenost je d – chyba tedy musí mít
váhu d nebo více, aby změnila logický stav zakódovaného qubitu, aniž by byla detekována jako
chyba. Nyní se podívejme na 7-qubitový Steaneův kód jako příklad a určíme, jaká je jeho vzdálenost.
Zde jsou generátory stabilizátoru pro tento kód. Připomeňme, že vzdálenost je minimální váha
n-qubitové Pauliho operace, která komutuje se všemi generátory stabilizátoru, ale sama o sobě není ve stabilizátoru
ani není proporcionální prvku stabilizátoru. Zjistíme, že tento kód má vzdálenost
tři. Určíme to tak, že nejdříve uvážíme libovolnou Pauliho operaci s váhou nejvýše dva a dojdeme k závěru,
že jediný způsob, jak může komutovat se všemi šesti generátory stabilizátoru, je, aby šlo o identitu, která je vždy prvkem
stabilizátoru. Předpokládejme tedy, že možné ne-identitní Pauliho matice tvořící tuto operaci – označme je
P a Q – se nacházejí na dvou nejlevějších pozicích. To je jen jeden případ a musíme zvážit
i všechna ostatní možná umístění těchto možných ne-identitních Pauliho matic – argument je ale pro všechna
umístění v zásadě stejný. Podle předpokladu tato operace komutuje se všemi šesti
generátory stabilizátoru, takže komutuje s tímto a také s tímto.
Q se shoduje s maticí identity v obou těchto generátorech – právě proto jsme vybrali tyto dva – a máme matice identity
na pěti nejpravějších pozicích této chyby. Dojdeme tedy k závěru, že P musí komutovat s X i Z,
protože jinak by tato chyba antikomutovala s jedním z těchto dvou generátorů. Ale jedinou Pauliho maticí, která
komutuje s X i Z, je identita – takže P musí být identita. A teď, když to víme,
můžeme zvolit dva další generátory stabilizátoru, které mají X a Z na druhé pozici zleva, a dojít
k podobnému závěru o Q. Takže chyba s váhou nejvýše 2 nemůže projít nezdetekována tímto kódem,
pokud to není operace identity, která je ve stabilizátoru – takže vlastně nejde o chybu.
Na druhou stranu existují Pauliho operace váhy tři, které komutují se všemi šesti generátory stabilizátoru,
ale nejsou proporcionální prvkům stabilizátoru – a zde jsou dva příklady. Dospěli jsme tedy k závěru, že tento
kód má vzdálenost tři. Posledním tématem, které v této lekci probereme, je oprava chyb pro
stabilizátorové kódy. Jako obvykle budeme předpokládat, že náš kód je specifikován n-qubitovými generátory stabilizátoru
P1 až PR. Začněme trochu přemýšlet o všech možných chybách, které mohou
nastat. Existuje 2 na R možných syndromů a jak jsem zmínil dříve v lekci, tyto syndromy rozdělují všechny
možné n-qubitové Pauliho operace do stejně velkých skupin – to znamená 4 na n děleno 2 na R Pauliho operací
v každé skupině. Takže když vidíme konkrétní syndrom, mohla být zodpovědná jakákoli z těchto 4 na n děleno 2
na R chyb. Trochu přepočítáváme, protože některé z těchto
chyb mají přesně stejný vliv na kódový prostor. Konkrétně, máme-li chybu E a vynásobíme E jakýmkoli
prvkem stabilizátoru S, dostaneme další chybu, která má na kódový prostor přesně stejný vliv jako E.
Jsou to tedy ekvivalentní chyby. Stabilizátor má 2 na R prvků a pokud to zohledníme, zjistíme,
že pro každý syndrom existuje 4 na n minus r tříd ekvivalence chyb, které mohly daný
syndrom způsobit. To znamená, že pokud R se nerovná n – v tom případě bychom měli jednorozměrný kódový prostor
a nemohli bychom kódovat žádné qubity – nebude možné opravit každou chybu, kterou dokážeme detekovat. Místo toho
musíme pro každý syndrom zvolit právě jednu korekční operaci v naději, že opravíme jen jednu třídu ekvivalentních
chyb. Jak tedy vybrat, jakou korekci pro daný syndrom provést? Přirozená strategie je vybrat
Pauliho operaci s nejmenší váhou, která způsobí daný syndrom – s tím, že Pauliho operace s menší váhou
představují pravděpodobnější vysvětlení syndromu. Ale pro některé modely šumu to nemusí být
platné – jiná přirozená strategie je nějak vypočítat nejpravděpodobnější chybu způsobující
daný syndrom. Pro tuto chvíli ale budeme uvažovat strategii, kde se pokoušíme opravit chyby výběrem Pauliho operace s nejmenší váhou způsobující
daný syndrom. Pro stabilizátorový kód se vzdáleností d tato strategie vždy umožní opravit chyby s váhou striktně
menší než polovina d – jinými slovy váhu nejvýše (d-1)/2. Stručně vysvětlím proč –
to ukáže mimo jiné, že 7-qubitový Steaneův kód dokáže opravit libovolnou chybu váhy jedna, a díky diskretizaci chyb to znamená,
že stejně jako 9-qubitový Shorův kód dokáže Steaneův kód opravit libovolnou
chybu na jednom qubitu. Jak to tedy funguje: představ si, že tento kruh reprezentuje všechny Pauliho
operace, jejichž výsledkem je syndrom samých plus jedniček – tedy syndrom, který naznačuje, že žádné chyby nenastaly
a vše je v pořádku. Mezi těmito operacemi jsou prvky stabilizátoru (nebo operace proporcionální prvkům stabilizátoru)
a také netriviální chyby, které nějak mění kódový prostor, ale kódem
nejsou detekovány. Z definice vzdálenosti víme, že každá Pauliho operace v této kategorii musí mít váhu alespoň
d, protože d je definováno jako minimální váha těchto operací. Máme také Pauliho operace,
které způsobují jiné syndromy – mohli bychom uvažovat každý syndrom zvlášť, ale zde si jen představme,
že se objevil jeden takový syndrom s. Nyní si představ, že E je chyba z tohoto
okruhu, která má váhu striktně menší než polovina vzdálenosti d. Nevíme sice,
že je to nutně Pauliho operace s minimální váhou v tomto okruhu – takže označme C jako operaci s minimální váhou v této množině (nebo jednu z nich, pokud je jich více se stejnou váhou).
Může tedy být, že c se rovná E, nebo nemusí. Protože ale C má minimální váhu, víme, že nemůže mít váhu větší než váha E –
protože C je také v dané množině a má minimální váhu. Korekční operace C tedy musí mít váhu striktně menší než polovina
d. Co se stane, když tuto korekci C aplikujeme na stav po chybě E?
Odpověď: stav, který dostaneme, je C krát E aplikované na původní kódování – nejdříve jsme vynásobili E (to byla chyba)
a pak jsme vynásobili C, abychom ji opravili. Tento součin musí být ve
stabilizátoru nebo proporcionální prvku stabilizátoru, a zde je důvod: zaprvé, protože E a C dávají
stejný syndrom, C krát E musí dát syndrom samých plus jedniček – protože pro daný generátor stabilizátoru
buď C i E oba komutují s daným generátorem, nebo oba antikomutují – musí to být stejné pro
oba, protože syndromy jsou stejné. A když se nad tím chvilku zamyslíš, plyne z toho, že C krát E musí
komutovat se všemi generátory stabilizátoru. A konečně C krát E musí být
ve stabilizátoru, protože jeho váha nemůže být větší než součet vah C a E, takže jeho váha
je striktně menší než d. To znamená, že E úspěšně opravíme, protože aplikace E a pak C nijak neovlivní
kódový prostor. Skvělé – ale je tu jeden problém, a to, že pro stabilizátorové
kódy obecně jde o výpočetně těžký problém najít operaci s nejmenší váhou způsobující daný
syndrom. A to platí dokonce i pro klasické kódy, o nichž v tomto kontextu můžeme přemýšlet jako o stabilizátorových kódech,
kde se jako tensorové faktory v generátorech stabilizátoru vyskytují pouze matice identity a Pauliho
matice Z. Takže na rozdíl od kroku kódování nám Cliffordovy operace tentokrát nepomáhají
a jediné rozumné řešení je volit konkrétní kódy, pro které lze dobré korekce vypočítat efektivně. Žádný obecný recept na to
neexistuje. Jednoduše řečeno, navrhování stabilizátorových kódů tohoto druhu je součástí uměleckého
umu při návrhu kvantových kódů. A to je dobré místo, kde v této lekci zastavit. Doufám, že se ke mně přidáš
v příští lekci, ve které se podíváme na konkrétní konstrukce kvantových kódů, včetně kódů, které ilustrují umění návrhu kvantových kódů
poměrně spektakulárním způsobem. Na shledanou.
pro příští lekci, ve které se podíváme na konkrétní konstrukce kvantových kódů, včetně kódů, které ilustrují uměleckou stránku návrhu kvantových kódů